So we seen a few examples measuring the time of execution of
toy programs, of a loop that does nothing. What we care about though
is the time of execution of our indexing code, so what I'm
going to do next is write a program to be able to test the
time of execution of indexing code. To get a good test we
need to make a big index, we need to fill up an index
with lots and lots of words, and we can do that by hand;
that would take a lot of time and effort. So what I'm going to
do instead, is to find a procedure that makes a
big index. So what it does is take in, a size,
and then it's going to, fill up an index with that
number of words. To fill up the index with that number
of keywords, we need to generate different words. So what
I've done is created a variable called letters, that is initially
is all A's. And as we go through the loop, we
go through the loop size number of times. We keep making
a new string. We add that string to the next, I'll
explain what make_string does later. We add that string to the
index, then we change the letters. And we're
going to keep increasing the letter once we get to z, we wrap around. For now
it's not too important to understand everything in this code, but
I do want to walk through the code a little bit.
So what this loop is doing is going through all the
positions and the letters are A and we filled this up with
eight different elements and we're going to go through those elements starting
from the last one going backwards, so this range loop goes from
the length minus 1 to 0, stepping by negative 1. We
are going to check each letter. If the letter is less than z,
that means we can increase and we are going to increase it
using this code here and I'll talk soon about the code that
turns letters into numbers, but what this expression does is get
the next letter. So if the letter was an a the result
after this will be a b, and we're going to replace the
letter at that position in the letters list, with the next
letter. If the letter is a z, we don't want to go
beyond the alphabet, so instead, we're going to set that letter to
a, and we're going to go back through the loop to find
the next letter. Once we found one less than z, we
break, we only need to change one letter. What the make_string
procedure does, that we call here. Is just turn that array into
one string. So it's going through the elements of P which
is this list of letters that keeps changing. And concatenating all those
letters into one string. So the whole point of this is to
allow us to easily make big indexes so we can run tests
on different size indexes. So let's try this in the Python shell.
First I'll show you what the result is when we use make
big index. We'll start with a fairly small one, so I'm passing
three is the size. What make big index gives us is an
index with three keywords: aaaaaaaa, aaaaaaab, aaaaaaac and for
each of them there's one url which is the name
fake. If we're passing in a bigger value, this
will have an index with a hundred keywords, so we're
going to passing a hundred is the size, we get
this big index, and you can see it's starting to
change the second from the last letter. To make sure
that each word is a different word than the next.
So, what we want to do now is look at
how the time of executions take for different size indexes. So,
let's make a really big index. So what we're going to do,
we'll make an index of size 10,000. And remember, our concern
is the time for lookups. It's the operation that's going to happen
most frequently. So we're not timing the time to make the
big index. Let's see what the time is to do a
lookup, and so I'll time the execution of looking up in
index 10,000 the keyword, and the word makes
a difference. So, first let's try looking up
the word udacity. Which, sadly, is not in
our index. We'd need a much bigger index
to get up to udacity. And the time of execution is shown here. So, it's 0.0008
seconds. So, still getting close to a millisecond,
but still quite fast. Let's make a bigger index.
This time we have a 100,000 keywords. going to take
a little longer to make it, but we're not
worrying about the time to make it now. What
we care is the time to do a look up.
So that took a long time. Let's see how, many entries there are, so we can look
at the very last element in our index. And we can see got to aaaafryd,
which I don't know to pronounce. Another way to see that, which
we didn't talk about yet, we can actually index from the
back using negative numbers, so if you use negative 1 as
the index, that will give us the last entry in the
list. So, now we'll try doing a timed execution. We're going to
look up in the 10,000 size index. And we'll
see the time's pretty similar to what it was before,
that time might vary a little bit, let's try
it once more, and again, it's just under a millisecond.
So now, we'll try, instead of the 10,000 index,
looking up in the 100,000 length index, the same look-up,
and we see that the time is now 10
times that, so it's now about 8.6 milliseconds whereas before
it was 0.9 milliseconds. And let's, for consistency, try that again.
We'll note that these timings vary a little bit, each time
we do it. And there's lots of reasons why the timing
varies. We're running lots of other things on the computer at the
same time. So it's not the case that we have total
control over the processor and are running exactly the same thing every
time. Because all of the other programs might be doing other
things. The other reason the time can vary is where things are
in memory. Sometime it's very quick to look up a
value in memory, sometimes it takes longer. And we're not going to
talk about the details of that. What matters is that, that
the time's roughly the same, each time we execute it. And
it really depends on the size of the input, in this
case it's the size of the input table. So when we
increase the size of the table to have 100,000 entires, it's
about 10 times as slow as when we had 10,000 entries.
So now let's have a few quizzes to see if you can guess how these timings work.